chinese mythology is a rich and varied
tradition
with influences from confucianism taoism
and buddhism similar to other cultural
mythologies the tales were often
considered
actual history featuring villains and
heroes
and some beings that defy categorization
one such figure is the tauti the most
enduring of the four
evils of chinese myth despite the
consistent descriptions of sharp
teeth strong claws and a notoriously
voracious appetite
this monster's genesis remains elusive
yet it also happens to share a name with
one of the most famous motifs in ancient
chinese art
so how did the bulging eyes and gaping
mouth of the tauti design
on bronze vessels turn into the taotie
monster that still intrigues us today
did i also mention it represents greed
and glutton
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
long before its appearance and written
history the tauti
existed in another documented form
ancient
chinese art from the very start of the
bronze age the tauti
featured prominently in the patterns
lines and ornaments of bronze items
precursors to written storytelling these
beast-faced designs
later called the tauti motif were
symmetrical representations of non-human
creatures
that famously dominated bronze art as
early as the shang dynasty
and enduring into the joe dynasties from
roughly 1600 to 256 bce
often these faces were rendered using a
multiple perspective
approach combining the profile views of
other animals to form a central
zoomorphic image
or beast the style is defined by its two
round bulging eyes
a gaping mouth that often featured no
lower jaw
heavy eyebrows ears and sometimes horns
naturally there are no written records
of what this bronze age iconography was
called when they were created
or what purpose the design served
archaeologists historians and other
scholars have pieced together plausible
explanations
and generated likely narratives but as
with all ancient scholarship this leaves
ample room for variations and
disagreement
in fact many scholars argue that the tau
t design
originated far earlier in neolithic
times
citing images of the tauti beast face
across multiple
artistic forms including jade objects
either way the tauti beast face is one
of the earliest
monstrous forms found in chinese art so
what
might the tauti have represented experts
present
several theories many of which revolve
around the ancient chinese religious
tradition of ancestor worship
some argue that the tauti designs depict
the animal helpers of male and female
shamans
who aided communication between the
living and the dead
other scholars assert that they are a
depiction of masks that were worn to
symbolize
ancestor spirits and still others
diverge a bit
and suggest that the tauti may represent
even older beliefs in nature deities and
spirits
of course there are some scholars who
say it's just an ornamental pattern and
not much else
but where's the fun in that this theory
ignores the very history of how the
bronze vessels came to be
who commissioned them the artisans who
made them and
why bronze age artisans created these
chinese vessels under the employment of
rich and powerful patrons
often royalty and nobility thus the
tauti
a frequent figure on such items might
also have served as a status symbol
meant to evoke the owner's social class
this interpretation holds up
especially when you consider that
beginning in the warring states period
the word tauti came to mean glutton
further many of these bronze vessels
were commissioned not for just
any wealthy patrons but for the shang
dynasty kings themselves
these kings believed to have gods as
their ancestors
maintained their power through conquest
and battle and successful harvests
sacrificial offerings to the king's
ancestral deities
and to the supreme deity d were
collected from lesser nobles in the form
of processions spoils from hunts and
animal and human sacrifice
the bronze vessels used in such tributes
ones that were adorned with early images
of tauti
were of utmost importance being
fundamental to the rituals
and thus instrumental in politics and
even the overall economy
in fact bronze making skills were homed
almost exclusively around ornamental
pursuits
rather than functional efforts like
weapons or agricultural tools
and so we can infer that the image of
the tauti
with its fangs horns and large eyes was
an integral component of early chinese
ceremonial
and religious life over time tauti
bronze vessels developed connections to
food for humans too
the feasts of ancient china were
notorious
in the joe dynasty after the bronze age
it was estimated that for some time
60 of the ruling king's servants were
dedicated to food-related duties
even as the majority of the population
lived with chronic deprivation and even
starvation
the filling of a bronze vessel with
sacrificial food
or food for a feast associated the tauti
motif with abundance
and underscored that having enough to
share was a sign of good manners and
social inclusion
the association of the word tauti with
gluttony
did not emerge until after this period
in the last three periods of the joe
dynasty
when the outbreak of war meant feeding
one's soldiers became more of a priority
than feasting
and further strain was placed on food
supplies the tauti motif on the bronze
vessels may have been seen as a sign of
extravagance
something to be avoided during wartime
it's no surprise then that the artistic
rendering of the tauti
face ended up inspiring mythology in the
form of the tauti
monster one of the four legendary
monsters or malevolences of chinese
mythology
in chinese mythology depictions of
monsters served an instructive or even
protective purpose and could be
portrayed repelling evil or helping
humans avoid real dangers
creatures like the tauti were considered
real and mythological
capable of occupying either or both
states
that said the mythological version of
tauti
with its insatiable appetite and
incredible greed
definitely inspired fear as it offered
instruction
i mean they were said to be man
devouring beasts after all
written narratives of the tauti monster
begin to appear around the 4th century
bce
starting with the zoa tradition or zoa's
commentary
which also happens to be the first
complete narrative work in chinese
literature
as the story goes in ancient times two
of the ruling gods had eight virtuous
sons each
and three other gods had one worthless
son each
these in turn were the three evils
malevolences
who maliciousness passed down through
the generations until the
time of emperor yao a legendary ruler in
chinese mythology
during yao's reign a fourth evil son
greedy for food and drink
was born to the jinyoung clan this one
could never be
satisfied he hoarded food refusing to
share with even those most desperate for
charity
he was called tauti and became the
fourth malevolence
luckily emperor yao's minister expelled
these four malevolences and their clans
to the four
edges of the earth one in each cardinal
direction
tasking them with warding off demons and
bad spirits
like most myths there are variations
including one from ming dynasty scholar
young shen
who wrote in this text that tauti is one
of the nine
children of the dragon who like to eat
and drink to excess
different origin story same defining
traits in the guideways through
mountains and seas or classic of
mountains and seas
a comprehensive text of chinese
mythology geography
nature and bestiary we find another
tauti like being in the text there's a
creature called the pyaouxu
it has a goat's body with a human's face
eyes behind its armpits
tiger's teeth and human hands it makes a
sound like a baby and is a man-eater
quite the combination of features
composed between the 4th and 1st
centuries bce
all the strange creatures depicted in
this comprehensive text
were believed to actually exist and it
was us
humans job to live among them safely
while the earliest
tauti bronze images don't seem to
resemble this monster
at all chinese philosopher and scholar
guo
considered an expert on the text insists
that this is the same
tauti mentioned in zoa's commentary
leading many scholars to agree
outside of chinese relics yu-gi-oh and a
few video games
physical depictions of the tau tea are
largely limited in modern culture
in fact tauti graced the silver screen
for the first time
in the 2016 film the great wall though
it is portrayed as an alien reptilian
species with dark green skin
and sharp teeth the body markings are
similar to the pattern
seen in ancient bronze chinese vessels
and the name
taute is similar enough we can roll our
eyes at matt damon's man bun
but in many ways this movie is another
example
of how traditional monster legends can
be adapted to fit modern narratives
and modern audiences i also see some
historical legitimacy in the adaptation
the green skin reminds me of the
neolithic jade figures with tauti like
decorative design
and some of the grunt taute soldiers
have human-like hands
tiger's teeth and eyes near their
shoulders
calling to mind the creature from
classic of mountains and seas
the queen of the species in the film
even has horns
again paying homage to the early tau t
bronze motifs
as for their motivation what is it they
want
to feed pure tauti
the director of the film has even
acknowledged ancient inspiration for his
gluttonous creatures
and gluttony is a timeless theme the
tauti
arose from visual motifs not only oral
or written stories
which not only makes its original
evolution unique
but demonstrates how the evolution of
mythology and monsters
is fluid the tauti is such a good
example of how mythology is
always changing visuals can construct
meaning
and in this example the evolution from
art to monster by way of mythology
can end with a timeless warning against
over consumption
or maleficence is it leffen
malevolences so it's there's different
names for them so potentially we could
just
change it has i haven't had a word this
bad in a long time
malevolence